qualche tempo fa ero a fare corso per la
ricerca del lavoro istituto superiore e
hanno chiesto a loro di dirmi cosa
avrebbe voluto fare e tra loro c'era
michele questo ragazzo che sembrava un
po timido che non voleva dirlo però
insistendo un po si è sciolto e alla
fine l'ha detto ha detto io voglio
andare a studiare recitazione a new york
perché la passione della recitazione
benissimo disse io perché non ha voluto
dirlo prima perché l'ho detto in classe
paio di settimane fa e la mia insegnante
mi ha riso in faccia davanti a tutti
ecco credo che nel suo piccolo questa
storia rappresenti perfettamente quella
che è la più grande sfida che abbiamo
davanti
come individui come società come cultura
da qui al prossimo secolo e forse oltre
non è la sfida del cambiamento globale
del riscaldamento globale non è la sfida
del terrorismo non è la sfida della
migrazione o di altre cose è una sfida
invece che se vinceremo ci permetterà di
vincere di slancio anche tutte queste
altre sfide e della sfida del
cambiamento dall impiego al lavoro un
cambiamento personale culturale e
sociale dall impiego al lavoro che cos'è
l'impiego
non è un caso che questa immagine di
charlie chaplin charlot si è rimasta
così popolare per oltre 80 anni perché
rappresenta perfettamente l'idea
dell'impiego impiego derivano a piegarsi
quindi adattare noi stessi ad entrare in
uno spazio del mercato del lavoro così
come ci è stato disegnato ed è
esattamente quello che fasciarlo in
questo caso e non è un caso che tra
l'altro pure in inglese rimane questo
curioso attimo perché si dice job job
deriva da gobba perché perché una volta
il lavoro prendi qui esposta li prendi
qui esposta lì e ti viene la gobba no
ecco il l'impiego è stato il centro
dell'era industriale del modello di
produzione e ricchezza industriale che
ha dato grandissimi benefici che però
adesso in grande crisi per via di tre
grandi cambiamenti uno tecnologico uno
economico e uno sociale e culturale
il primo quello tecnologico forse il più
affascinante
ci sono diversi studi che dicono che
oltre 50 per cento dei lavori nel
mercato del lavoro nostro americano sono
a rischio di essere sostituiti da
macchine nei prossimi anni
non stiamo parlando solamente di droni o
di stampanti 3d ma soprattutto
intelligenza artificiale
forse avete sentito che qualche
settimana fa un computer di google ha
vinto ago un gioco molto complesso
cinese il più grande campione di questo
gioco e questo vuol dire che forse siamo
molto vicini intelligenza artificiale e
infatti notizia di poche settimane fa
uno dei più grossi studi legali
americani ha assunto se volete ho
acquistato un intelligenza artificiale
per fare consulenza in ambito legale
ecco questo dice tantissimo so che su
questo tema c'è una grande discussione
qualcuno dice ah siete nel udisti i
nudisti erano quelli che vi ricordate
spaccavano macchinari nell'inghilterra
dell'ottocento i telai meccanici perché
pensavano che la b rubato loro il lavoro
ecco però forse siamo vicini a
un'accelerazione esponenziale della
tecnologia che qualche impatto l'avrà
sicuramente sul mercato del lavoro
c'è addirittura una ricerca del world
economic forum che parla di 5 milioni di
posti lavoro che spariranno entro il
2020 cioè domani
questo è il primo fattore tecnologico il
primo cambiamento
il secondo grande cambiamento economico
ci sono dei concetti legati all'economia
che noi usiamo ancora tantissimo ma che
sono in profonda crisi
uno di questi concetti e quello di
produttività venete per esempio noi qui
dentro in questa stanza 100 120 persone
che ascoltano un'altra persona che parla
che produttività abbiamo qui
per un certo tipo di economia se una
persona si mettesse quei fori a creare
un oggetto di bigiotteria avrebbe più
produttività di noi però noi sappiamo
che stiamo creando qualcosa di
importante di più importante qui però
non è tangibile
il concetto e produttività va benissimo
quando si produce qualcosa di materiale
ma quando siamo una società collegata
coi servizi soprattutto è andato nei
servizi diventa molto più difficile
misurarlo un altro concetto è quello
della schering economy se volete si è
invertito il rapporto tra fatturato e
dipendenti
una volta l'azienda che aveva più
fatturato aveva anche più dipendenti
adesso non è più così anche per via
della digitalizzazione whatsapp quando è
stato acquistato da facebook per 22
miliardi e passa di dollari aveva 55
dipendenti
il margine operativo per aziende come
airbnb o huber è piccolissimo ma
riescono a sostenersi perché servono
milioni di persone e però impiegano
qualche centinaio di persone un terzo
grande cambiamento è sociale culturale
non siamo più così tanto interessati a
fare gli stakanovisti anche se lo
facciamo lo stesso ma siamo forse più
così tanto interessati ad avere i
vestiti firmati o la ferrari perché il
più figo di tutti è quello che va in
giro con la bici elettrica e maglietta e
questo vuol dire tantissimo dal punto di
vista del lavoro quindi dalla
dell'impiego sta per finire
dovremo essere terrorizzati no
preoccupati un po sì però c'è una
grandissima opportunità forse la più
grande che abbiamo da questo cambiamento
ed è proprio quella di passare dall
impiego al lavoro anche perché l'impiego
non sta funzionando
ci sono diversi tipi di ricerche che
parlano del fatto che dal 50 all 80 per
cento delle persone detesta proprio
lavoro o non gli piace ed è quello che
fanno
otto ore al giorno per 30 40 anni
spendiamo lo stesso tempo a lavorare che
a dormire se voi doveste avere una
persona che soffre di insonnia ne
direste di dormire ovunque sopra un
tavolo seduto per terra
no perché non dormirebbe si sveglierebbe
incavolato nero la mattina no
e però noi diciamo alle persone trovano
un lavoro qualsiasi basta che ti dia uno
stipendio è un po curioso se ci pensate
perché siamo in una cultura in cui ci
dicono segui la tua passione fai quello
che ti piace è un po come quando la
fidanzata di dice ha ben fai quello che
vuoi
panico in quel momento tu sei
esattamente che mai riuscirai a fare
quello che tu vuoi in nessun caso
possibile ma questo al di là degli
scherzi anche un grande impatto dal
punto di vista proprio fisico nelle
persone ci sono degli studi che
analizzano bene il fatto che le persone
che vanno in pensione più tardi si
ammalano più tardi e le persone che
vanno in pensione prima sembravano prima
addirittura c'è una scala medica che si
chiama scala di homs onora e che mette
in classifica gli eventi traumatici non
fisici che portano a una malattia per
esempio la morte del coniuge o di un
figlio è il primo posto se vi muore il
partner o il figlio è probabile che
anche voi è più probabile che un
prossimo futuro anche voi vi ama le reti
al decimo posto c'è la pensione
quindi noi abbiamo milioni di persone
che lavorano tutta la vita per fare una
cosa che detestano vanno in pensione si
ammalano e muoiono e terribile questo se
ci pensate è una stata una grande
opportunità però forse finalmente
arrivato il momento di cambiare
non ha più senso parlare di work life
balance cioè di vita da una parte e
lavoro dall'altra come se lavorare non
fosse vita non le due cose devono andare
insieme il lavoro e forza con una
direzione
il lavoro è l'espressione dell'energia
vitale orientata verso un obiettivo di
lungo periodo
so che sembra molto filosofico ma
andiamo sul pratico
qual è la grande opportunità che per
esempio l'accelerazione tecnologica farà
rimanere molti più lavori che impieghi
perché per esempio io non assumerò mai
una infermiera robot per accudire mia
madre quando arriva spero 120 anni come
probabilmente non mi emozionerò mai per
un chitarrista robotico
a proposito del prossimo speaker
scherzare su questo palco ecco quindi ci
sono delle cose che solo le persone
possono fare per le persone e li abbiamo
delle grandi opportunità cosa possiamo
fare concretamente nel welfare ci sono
degli aspetti che vanno sicuramente
cambiati per esempio partendo
dall'educazione abbiamo visto anche
all'inizio siamo il paese della
montessori
eppure abbiamo una scuola che tende a
formare tendete bene attenzione alla
parola formare cioè come se noi
dovessimo fare in qualche modo le
persone per entrare in quel buco del
mercato del lavoro invece che lasciare
che siano loro a formare il lavoro alla
società comunque dicevo per formare
impiegati e operai che sono esattamente
le categorie che stanno sparendo
dovremmo invece contare molto di più
sulle vocazioni quindi inserire per
esempio un bilancio delle competenze
obbligatorio in ogni anno scolastico
della scuola dell'obbligo e sicuramente
una cosa da fare io guarda ho visto
moltissime simulazione i colloqui di
lavoro
la prima domanda che fanno nell'ottanta
per cento dei casi e mi parli di lei
panico come mi parli della ritmo mi sono
preparato sull'azienda le persone non
sanno cosa sono
cosa vogliono un altro aspetto è quello
dell'ambiente di lavoro
finiamola di portare il ping pong o la
palestra in azienda va benissimo ma non
è portando la vita fuori dentro
l'azienda che sinistra del problema
bisogna avere le porte girevoli tra
l'azienda e vita e il vita di tutti i
giorni con lo smart work in si può
lasciare le persone essere molto più
flessibili sul lavoro e possono essere
produttivi e flessibili se fanno
qualcosa che per loro interessa cioè il
lavoro e non impiego e anche ad esempio
nei salari dare con partecipazione
azionaria al alle persone che lavorano
dentro le aziende farli sentire parte di
un progetto più che al servizio e questo
progetto ma soprattutto quello che a me
preme di più e l'intermediazione nel
mercato del lavoro
abbiamo un mercato del lavoro che
intermediata in maniera depressiva
inefficace e vi dico pure di più poco
equa quella degli annunci più curriculum
che deprimono un sacco di persone
deprimere il mercato del lavoro oltre 70
per cento delle persone trova lavoro con
le persone in italia nel mondo e non
sono raccomandazioni
dobbiamo ritornare a mettere la persona
al centro anche nel mercato del lavoro
e queste per esempio quello che fa
la mia start up the club e tra poco sarà
anche qui ad alessandria
ma tutto questo per dire va bene questo
è quello che possiamo fare fuori ma cosa
possiamo fare noi perché ogni grande
cambiamento deve partire da noi
anzitutto è secondo me la risposta un po
tornare bambini quando siamo bambini
ogni cosa che facciamo una figata
ma non solo per noi anche per gli altri
facciamo due schizzi così sul sul foglio
e dicono capolavoro la mia bambina di 11
mesi gattona quella fatta con le manine
e mia nonna impazzisce la sua nonna
impazzisce ok sentite guardate guarda
mamma che capriola ho fatto è un vero
atleta guarda mamma una lucertola morta
è fantastico tesoro però dentro smentito
che era la torta al di là degli scherzi
e tutto quello che facciamo è
espressione di noi stessi e le altre
persone vedono che l'espressione di noi
stessi e quindi ci incoraggiano se
diciamo voglio fare l'esploratore il
calciatore eccetera dicono si prova
magari ci riuscirai però a un certo
punto smettiamo di essere bambini
smettiamo di essere queste cose piccole
che vanno in giro con gli occhioni
grandi
cominciamo essere potenziali adulti che
devono essere introdotti le durezze
della vita
allora quando diciamo voglio diventare
esploratore dicono va bene ma magari
studiata contabilità per esempio intanto
no erano cosa facciamo cerchiamo di
riottenere quell'approvazione che
avevamo all'inizio
cominciamo a fare lo stesso sport che
fanno i cuginetti ci vestiamo come fanno
i compagni di scuola
andiamo alla università insieme i nostri
amici e dopo di che troviamo un lavoro
che vuole la fidanzata o quale che
vogliono i genitori non sempre però
succede spesso è quella cosa continua
cominciamo a comprare oggetti che ci
permetta di offrirci proprio come diceva
mirko nella prima presentazione perché
le pubblicità dicono compra questa
macchina compra questo detersivo non
perché ti serve ma perché ti definisca
per che definisca the agli occhi di te
stesso e agli occhi degli altri e non è
un caso che noi diciamo sono un avvocato
sono un medico sono un idraulico e non
faccio l'avvocato il medico l'idraulico
perché lo status lo stato si definisca
però alla fine non sappiamo chi siamo
questo è il flusso dell'insuccesso o
dell'impiego cioè faccio qualcosa
o qualcosa in cambio che sia materiale o
che sia stato sociale e grazie a questo
mi definisco questo funziona alla grande
per fare le cose per averle però non
basta mai per definirci e lascia la fine
delle persone insoddisfatte
quello che invece dobbiamo fare il
flusso del lavoro il flusso del successo
cioè sono so chi sono io faccio qualcosa
che mi permetta di esprimermi e questo
che avrò ottenuto o alla fine chi sia
tanto che sia poco che si sa fare
l'eremita in una grotta che vive con una
ciotola di riso essere prossimo steve
jobs sarà quello che mi permette di
esprimermi e se io lavoro non ho
interesse invece che avere un impiego
non ho interesse ad avere tre macchine
di lusso o 5 smartphone mansi metto la
ricchezza la mia ricchezza disposizione
non mi farà saltare in un centro
commerciale per capire chi sono
perché lo saprò già e quello che faccio
quello che sono mi permette di
esprimermi
se michele adesso come spero ea new york
e sta vivendo nel peggior sobborgo del
queen's dove ci sono i ratti dove ci
sono gli spacciatori e deve andare al
mcdonald's per lavorare per pagarsi le
bollette ma starà facendo il corso e
recitazione che ama fare sarà più di
successo lui sarà un elemento più che
darà più contributo alla società della
sua insegnante che ha preso un impiego
quando aveva 20 30 anni perché era fissa
era uno stipendio fisso e adesso si
sveglia ogni mattina incavolata per
mondo deve sfogare la sua frustrazione
su di lui chi è che avrà vinto alla fine
ecco come ultimo messaggio voglio
lasciarvi un piccolo esercizio da fare a
casa quando tornata a casa disegnate una
lapide e pensate che sia la vostra
lapide e pensate a cosa volete che ci
sia scritto sopra lo so mettere
imbarazzo fa paura però la morte il
nostro ultimo tabù non vogliamo pensare
a lungo termine viviamo costantemente
dentro il presente una volta aspettando
il medico pensavamo a noi stessi di 10
20 anni adesso abbiamo facebook nello
smartphone
siamo sempre in versione presente non
pensiamo a lungo termine il bello è
pensato a lungo termine e soprattutto a
noi da morti il fatto che le cose come
il denaro il successo lo stato personale
non saranno più interessanti rimarrà
solo il valore e l'idea di lungo periodo
e questo vorrà dire aver trovato una
direzione
dopodiché basterà solo mettersi in
viaggio bisogna mettersi al lavoro
riccardo mazzon